if you had to take back the throne from
your ghost father what would you do
you'll need to fight magicians demons
horrifying monsters in order to reclaim
your place as king I'm going to break
down the mistakes made what you should
do and how to beat the Osama demon in
ranking of Kings part two this Prince
will die trying to fight an invincible
demon from Hell Boi here is the son of a
dead King a dead mother a mean
stepmother and his stronger younger
stepbrother has just stolen his position
as the new king the son of a giant and
born without any powers deaf and mute
Boi has gone to the underworld to train
with the best of the best Lord desper in
order to get strong enough become the
one true king complimenting his course
him his best friend kagay gets news that
his kingdom has just been taken over by
unknown forces and his stepmother and
her trusted followers have tried to
escape the kingdom and now he must go
back to save them meanwhile in the boss
Kingdom everything has gone horribly
wrong Boi's stepmother Queen healing
after talking to her generals have
decided to try and take back the kingdom
entering the gate she discovers who is
behind the attack their Castle's trusty
adviser this magic mirror who they
discover is Lady Morano a witch that
king boss was close to and who helped
him form this Kingdom years ago thinking
she died long ago they ask what she
wants but she reveals she's been
plotting this Kingdom's Destruction for
years and wants to end this country
Queen healing then realizes that they've
just fallen into a trap Morano's
hellhounds show up and prepare to attack
her but her guard drusy tries to defend
her using his overpowering strength he
pulls it off but quickly gets exhausted
and they all realize that Morano is
trying to tire them out she reveals she
recently freed criminals from the
underworld and she unleashes them onto
Queen healing and her men her men focus
on defending her from the criminals
while drusy yells for her to run away
before it's too late trying to escape
she runs into this unknown criminal the
man that will soon kill her son Oaken
Queen healings other guard and knocks
Oaken down and helps her Escape but she
suddenly gets her neck cut making Queen
healing realize that this terrifying
enemy is Unstoppable Thinking Fast she
blinds him with a magic spell making him
run away in fear healing then heals an
how redundant drinking more magic potion
to enhance her powers but she runs out
of energy just as more hellhounds
surround her and that's when this man
saves her it's her old bodyguard opis
opis tells her to run betraying Morano
momentarily understanding that he served
Queen healing for many years Morano
amazingly quickly forgives him for going
against her but warns him not to do it
again duy knocked out suddenly wakes up
and sees his Queen in trouble making him
angry and full of Rage he rushes to save
her killing everything in his path like
an absolute monster taking massive hits
he starts to quickly lose more blood and
queen healing can do nothing but watch
in fear not being able to handle seeing
his former partners get hurt opies asks
miranja why she is doing all of this and
she says she wants to free boss from his
family responsibilities and go back to
how their life was before he became king
she reveals to him that she recently
transferred the dead King Soul into
Boi's younger step brother Prince da and
this way these two will be able to soon
reunite when this is all over and go
back to the old days she then orders
opies to take her back inside and leave
Queen healing fate up to her evil
minions okay these people were way too
excited to get brutally murdered if I
was them in order to beat Morano I would
have relied on my knowledge of royal
family inbreeding FBI profiling
techniques and that's scene in season 1
episode one of Game of Thrones let me
explain king of giants king boss made a
deal with the demon to make him the
strongest giant ever and help create an
awesome Kingdom but in exchange for his
soul and miranja betray the demon and
put boss's Soul after he died into his
youngest child Boi shunga brother died
up but manano is really in love with
boss and now wants to kill the rest of
his family so they could be together
forever and boss is like what and now
here we are but at this point Queen
healing coming back to take her castle
she acted way too emotional she thinks
her son Boi was murdered in the
Underworld by one of her own men but he
wasn't and recently found out mirango
brought her dead husband back to life
and she knows the soul of her data is
not dead which means her stress levels
must be out the Wazoo and if I was a
babe Queen I would have first chilled
out and not acted like an idiot and
realize that we come as a royal family
first which means we should have family
connections this means just like in gab
of Thrones in this land of Royals
everyone should have known everyone and
if that's the case it makes no sense why
we just didn't go up to a neighboring
Kingdom and asked for help instead of
trying to fight a witch and an army of
Underworld bad guys Morano clearly will
do anything that she likes to live how
she did in the past with king boss and
it's clearly not this reality this means
that her mindset likely could come from
a mindset that is filled with anxiety
and underlying depression which if we
think about it this chick has been
living in a mirror plotting her evil
plans for years at this point it's
amazing she hasn't gone insane or has
she this means that her psycho motives
are coming from a point of desperation
means we could have predicted that she
would do whatever it takes to achieve
her goal even if it means destroying
everyone and everything around her
basically any type of strategic IC
planning would have been way better than
Queen hing's running gun approach gosh
it was so stupid meanwhile Oaken reaches
the kingdoms nearby town and begin
slaughtering innocent civilians easily
destroying everything in his path and
just then Boi and his men come back from
the underworld and witness the horror of
their people Captain here informs Boi
that his trainer has told him about the
man they've just run into known as one
of the most horrifying criminals from
the underworld boji must not fight Oak
no matter what he tells him that desper
will arrive soon but until then he will
deal with Oaken and sends Boi to go save
his mother instead back in the castle
drusy carries Morano when they get
betrayed by one of the criminals Morano
rescued this mustache man knocks opis
out and steals Morano saying he doesn't
give a about this Kingdom and wants
to use her magic to make him Rich back
in the kingdom druy is about to die
trying to save Queen healing and out of
options she calls out for her husband
king boss to help captured by Queen
healings men and hidden from Morano till
they figure out be been here while
watches over king boss and that's when
he hears his wife screams and uses his
super strength to open his cage but
stops when beben here gets in his way
not wanting to harm his former servant
he doesn't leave his cell meanwhile
Bean's pet mitsumata comes to Queen
healings rescue not knowing what this
monster is he tells her that Boi saved
him when he was a baby snake and now he
belongs to one of her soldiers Lord bben
and just then another one of Morano's
underworld prisoners shows up and
attacks mitsumata but that's when KAG
and Prince Boi finally show Boi uses his
new training skills and stops the green
monster shocked to see her son still
alive and now not a pathetic weakling
the two Rite after many episodes apart
and is impressed with Boi's strength the
green prisoner stops fighting and
introduces himself as jigon and says
that he respects Boi's great strength
the rest of the devil hellhounds also
stop fighting and join Boi's side and
KAG advises him to send these demon dogs
and prisoners back to the underworld and
tells them that he remembers seeing a
secret entrance under this castle that
leads to the underworld this is how
Morano snucker bad guys into this
Kingdom shocking Queen healing as she
hears this mitsumata warns Boi that they
need to hurry because his old babysitter
damas that also tried to kill him was
ordered by Queen boss to destroy the
underworld entrance concerned that Damas
has switched sides Queen healing asks
her son if he's truly ready to face the
man that tried to kill him earlier Boi
gets nervous but KAG convinces him that
he can do it drusy says that they will
stay here to protect Queen healing in
the meantime so Boi Kake and the rest of
the creatures from the underworld set
off back underneath the castle Damas and
hakaru reached the gate to the
underworld and prepared to destroy it
but they hear someone approaching from
the other side Damas orders
inexperienced toaru to hide and he
prepares for combat a huge Army enters
and they introduce themselves as the
order of the underworld they claim that
King desha has sent them to return the
prisoners that escaped the underworld
and punish the one who stole them in the
first place domas has no idea what
they're talking about but he tries to
stop them anyways he climbs up these
steps to force these soldiers to attack
him in smaller groups and the two sides
engage in combat okay we're out gunned
right now the order is a powerful group
of knights from the underworld it means
that what Damas did actually is a smart
move as he was outnumbered more than we
can count however if I was him I would
have taken it one step further it's
noted that this is the only entrance
into the castle and the only way out is
going through this staircase this means
that we can use this advantage against
this mini Army by creating a bottleneck
combat strategy I would first head
further up the staircase and from here
the underworld soldiers would be forced
to come at me higher up on the staircase
and this would help shift to my
advantage since due to their armor troop
size and the surface area of the
staircase this would essentially force
them to restrict their movement and
reduce the importance of their sheer
Army size meaning I could take fewer
soldiers on almost one or two at a time
instead of all of them at once the
higher up on the stairs would allow me
to just even push or kick most of the
soldiers off of the platform and let
gravity take care of the rest also due
to the fact that they are wearing armor
it means their fall to the ground will
be more brutal you all know the term
terminal velocity it's the speed of
which how fast something Falls and it
will only be reached after someone Falls
for around 12 seconds this means that
each soldier that we pushed off of the
stairs from a height of 60 ft would
actually not reach terminal velocity
which means we can adjust how brutal we
want their deaths to be we just made a
beautiful moment of interactive game of
Tetris death amazing Damas tries to
reason with them but they don't listen
and just then one of the troops nearby
comes up behind hakaru and is about to
kill him when King Das arrives he tells
hakaru and damas that this whole
situation in the human world is messed
up as hell boss kingdom is on the brink
of collapse and he has to come stop the
one person responsible for this mess and
the one who stole his prisoners Morano
he warns them that she has also stolen
the most dangerous criminal from the
underworld King desha and des's brother
Oaken and that's when jigang lands in
front of everyone holding Prince boji
and KAG Damas and hakaru see boji alive
and are shocked but happy Dumas tells
Boi that he's sorry he betrayed him and
huaro had nothing to do with it but boji
starts having a panic attack seeing toas
trying to show his loyalty to Boi he
tries to well kick a bucket but realizes
that his body is too strong to get hurt
King desha then try to capture their
escaped criminal jigang and desha
incapacitates him with a lightning bolt
he gives Boi the rundown of what his
father might be up to and warns him that
the king boss will likely help Morano in
her evil plans since they were very
close and they both have committed great
sins together he tries to take jigang
back to the underworld jail but boji
stops him and says the two have become
good friends getting pissed off desha
prepares to fight but Boi puts down his
weapon confused he calls up his brother
and the man that trained Boi desperate
he tries to ask his brother what the
hell's Boi's problem is but desper
switches topics and tells him that he
needs to stop his plans to invade boss
Kingdom immediately since king boss is a
top ranking King it means that he is the
strongest of rulers even stronger than
King desha the only one who can take
boss out as his son Prince boji and
desper convinces Desa to let boji take
king boss and Mir mjo out when the time
comes and then after he'll also be able
to take out the demon who Morano's Soul
belongs to the true Puppet Master behind
all of this convinced of des's more
sneaky and less risky plan to return
everything back to normal him and his
troops leave back to the underworld to
wait it out Chang then tells Boi that he
must return as well but thanks Boi for
his friendship Damas then begs Boi for
forgiveness and tells him that he was
just following Morano's orders but Boi
runs away crying KAG gets mad and tells
him that they'll have to prove
themselves to Boi when the time comes
and he runs to cheer boji up doas
apologizes to hakaru for getting him
into this mess but hakaru cheers doas up
and says they should first burn the
underworld entrance and then they get
their act together so they can make it
up to Prince Boi heading back out Boi
runs into opies passed out he wakes up
and kagay tells him that there are
demons everywhere once loyal to Boi's
family he tells them that they should
leave because lady Morano can't be
stopped and she will soon kill queen
healing and take over this Kingdom
nervous he then reveals to Boi and KAG
what everyone else knows and tells him
the king boss is alive and has possess
possessed his younger brother's body
died shocking Boi he realizes what king
desha was whispering about back under
the castle aies suspects that Boi father
is trying to fulfill Morano's dream
because he's in debt to Morano OPI says
he has no choice but to fight Prince Boi
and that's when he sees his strong Aura
shocked that he is now much stronger
than he was before KAG then informs him
that Boi was trained by desper and is
now much stronger than him proud of him
obies decides he can't try and fight him
and tells Boi to try and stop Morano and
take his rightful place on the throne as
Boi and KAG bit him farewell he passes
out again from his injuries on the way
to save the day KAG gives Boi the game
plan defeat the rest of the prisoners
who escape the underworld and then deal
with king boss and Morano sounds simple
and then they run into Oak and running
past them freaking them out they decide
to follow him El where the rest of the
underworld prisoners take a break to
enjoy their freedom when Oaken finally
shows back up Boi and KAG arrive nearby
not realizing that Morano is the one in
the mirror KAG instructs Boi to stop
because something doesn't feel right
they watch Oaken easily killed this one
prisoner to save Morano forcing mustache
guy to try and Escape Boi spots him and
decides to try and stop him okay Boi
just acted really stupid Boi made the
critical mistake of going balls to the
wall without thinking Oaken here is one
of the Three Brothers King deser desper
and Oaken brother number one inherited
all of his sick father's Powers brother
number two only got a little and Oaken
didn't get any but later in life he
developed powers of immortality which
caused him to lose his mind he's Pure
Evil and loves committing Act of
violence and loves watching people die a
slow death if I was Boi understanding
the Dynamics within the enemy group was
way more important than rushing in bji
just acted like how most humans do
jumping into a solution thinking he was
making progress by acting fast when in
reality he was just trying to avoid
being uncomfortable in this uncertain
situation by rushing to come up with a
half-ass plan in fact obies himself was
dumb as hell for thinking Boi could have
taken Morano by himself after chasing
him he stops up on this wall mustache
guy tries to throw poison in his face
but nothing happens and KAG reveals to
him that even though boji doesn't have
his father's Powers all Giants are
resistant to all poison making Boi
stronger than he looks boji then knocks
him out and ties him up just as oan
reaches that he tries to attack Boi but
he easily Dodges his attacks aranjo
watching from the distance is impressed
at how much stronger Boi has gotten but
tells Boi that he can't defeat Oaken Boi
attacks and tries to find his weak point
but he quickly realized is that this
evil criminal doesn't have any Oaken
laughs like a psycho and Morano tells
Boi that he will die if he continues
boji tries his second secret move but
nothing happens and he starts to panic
Mirano then does something strange and
tells kagi that they should run KAG
thanks her and goes to tell Boi not
knowing why she just helped Boi she
questions what's going on not realizing
that she's turning good Boi jumps onto
this wall for safety but Oaken outsmarts
him by attempting to kill mustache man
near him forcing boji to come down and
face him up close where boji will be
more vulnerable Mirano tells kagi that
Oaken is Immortal and can't die
suspicious KAG asks her how she knows
this and she reveals to them what
everybody else already knows she is the
famous Morano the one who betrayed Boi's
Kingdom and got his mother killed
elsewhere mitsumata and the Gang Dro
Queen healing off at this safe house but
run into opies passed out waking him up
he tells them that Mirano has just been
taken away by Underworld prisoners
ashamed for betraying Queen healing he
tells her that he just wanted to ease
Morano's pain since her situation is
much more complicated than it looks are
you freaking kidding me he tells druy
here to go save Morano and queen healing
surprisingly forgives opis and heals his
injuries just as dasas and hokar come
from beneath the castle saying they
finally destroyed the underworld
entrance Queen healing is shocked to see
them after what they tried to do to Boi
blows up on them sincerely apologizing
she thinks they have more important
things to work worry about and forgives
these two instead thankfully Damas
informs her that Boi just saved this
Kingdom earlier from King Desha's
Invasion and saved the whole Kingdom she
asks where Boi is but no one knows
hearing this AIS informs them that Boi
went in that direction and toasu hakaru
go to get him wanting to pay Queen
healing back AIS also joins she tries to
join but truy offers for him to go
instead telling her that she should be
kept safe while her bodyguard here
watches over her back in the prison cell
king boss tells Bon what's really really
going on telling him that Morano is the
one behind this she's been undercover
living in their family's mirror for
years he mentions how important he is to
her she is the one that helped him make
a deal with the devil to screw over his
first child Boi in order to gain extra
powers and become the strongest King in
the world he also reveals mirano's
backstory how they met and how her
mother was also killed by her own
neighbors and whatever but inside this
body trapped within his own mind the
real Prince daid listens in to what his
father is saying and here's Morano at
backstory and finally realizes the
mirror he grew up with banjo has no one
in her life that understands her except
for king boss and this is the reason
behind her plans and whatever biben
tells king boss that he consense that
Boi will be in trouble soon and will go
to save him but warns king boss that if
he runs into Morano he will try to kill
her back outside finding out Morano is
the one in the mirror KAG tries to kill
her while Boi finally realizes that he
can't beat Oaken and that's when a
lightning bolt comes crashing down
announcing the arrival of Boi's trainer
desper along with Captain showing up to
save Boi desper says he's proud of him
and quickly calls his brother King desha
to shoot another lightning bolt at Oaken
but Oaken thinks fast and uses his sword
to direct the electricity through his
body and away from his heart shocking
everybody at his four-dimensional chess
move and he starts to overcome his
weakness of lightning okay well they
just messed up their biggest move Oaken
just redirected King dasha's lightning
strike his armor is made of silver the
single most conductive metal meaning it
attracts cracks electricity and
lightning can pass through it easily
this made him an easy target even if
desha wasn't trying to aim at him but
Oaken figured out his obvious game plan
from the first strike and easily
deflected it by making his sword act as
conductor lightning being an actual
weakness of Oak means that he would
likely have been able to defend himself
from King desa's strikes even if he
wasn't warned by the first strike
moments earlier this means trying to
stop him by lightning while a good plan
was done in the wrong way if I was them
I would have either let aboji get slain
by and not rushed in when we did and
instead would have used the element of
surprise to strike Oaken when he least
expected it or if he wanted to let boji
live cuz I mean he is a cute little boy
I would have first gathered a nearby
water source in a bucket I would have
added a ton of salt inside of it
and not only is water generally a good
conductor but High conductivity through
water is usually determined by its
saline conditions from here I would have
radioed in King desha and a coordinated
assault where we would have splashed
Oaken with a bucket full of salt and
water at the same time as king Desa shot
down another bolt of lightning on him
this way Oaken would have been unable to
redirect the lightning and would have
felt the full force of his brother's
strike Captain tries to charge at Oaken
but easily gets stabbed leaving desper
all alone Thinking Fast he uses his
analytical mind and intuition to sense
oaken's strike dodging it and bringing
Oaken in close in he tells Oaken that
he'll never abandon him and thinks he
can turn him good but no now stabbed he
falls down while KAG screams his brains
out boji makes the last desperate move
knocking oaken's mask off he then
realizes that desperate is still alive
seeing them confused by oaken's tactics
Morano tells them that oaken's special
move is avoiding the vitals of his
victims in order to watch them die a
slow death regenerating back to full
strength Ogen then knocks Boi back and
gets ready to kill him KAG runs to save
him by swallowing him completely but he
easily rips through K's body critically
injuring him forcing him desper and
Captain to watch as Oaken pierces Boi's
leg and then his chest with everybody
defeated and now on the brink of death
Oaken finally sits down to rest counting
down the minutes until everyone dies
Morano then has a sudden change of heart
and mind controls this dead person
nearby going up to desper she holds him
kaga and Boi and transports them into
this strange World Boi and desper don't
know where they are but see someone in
the distance who looks like KAG but it's
his mother desper then sees KAG on the
other side of the river and realizes
they are on the entrance of the
afterlife seeing K's mother calling out
to him he realizes that if kagay crosses
this River he will never come back to
life him and Boi tried calling out to
him but find out they're actually inside
K's mind and can't interfere with his
thoughts reaching close to his mother
K's boat then gets stopped by Morano
confusing desper and boji on what's
going on since she is supposed to be
evil Morano tells KAG that if he crosses
this River he will never come back to
life this makes KAG remember his best
friend Boi and realizes that he must
survive to take care of him he then
shouts to his mother that he will see
her one day and turns around reaching
the shore Morano warns kagay that even
if he returns back to life he won't be
able to save anyone but KAG tells her
she's wrong and happily runs off to
reunite with Boi in real life returning
from the brink of death meanwhile inside
King boss's mind the real da sits with
this girl that he met while being
trapped inside of his own body it's
really weird figuring out that this is
the consciousness of Morano he tries to
understand what she went through and
finally helps her spirits turn good and
sees her disappear in front of him he
thinks that mirango might still have a
shot at turning good outside the
courtyard mitsumata find finally reaches
Boi seeing him injured he tries to
attack Oaken but easily gets his ass
kicked as Oaken begins feasting on his
flesh about to die he gets saved by
beben finally showing up and slices
oaken's body in half rise the rest of
Boi's Squad shows up Oaken then heals up
quick and bben warns everybody that
Oaken can only be defeated by being tied
up and locked away beben says he knows
somebody who has the powers that can
heal Boi deas then tries fighting Oaken
first but gets stopped by oaken's secret
move confused be warns him that Oak has
the power to throw objects at people
really fast and tells everyone that his
sword is almost impossible to destroy
seeing the craziness they finally
believe him and Damas regrets trying to
fight him one-on-one using teamart they
all attack him taking turns together
side attacks tag teams and it's amazing
being trained by his brother desper
years ago Oaken then switches to full
psycho mode and turns into the true
sword King of the underworld he knocks
everybody out in seconds with no choice
but to try again the group somehow
recovers dizzy tired and on energy and
raise their weapons once more back in
the afterlife Boi and desper see Mirano
run into her own dead mother and Boi's
mother across the river Queen Sheena
says that she doesn't hate Morano
anymore for what she did to her but
tells her that her evil plans have left
her all alone in the real world Marano's
mother senses something strange in her
and then realizes that Mirano will never
be able to join her in the afterlife
unable to lie she confesses that she
hired an army years ago to overthrow and
kill Boi's mother but the people that
she hired betrayed her and killed her
too desperate to survive with king boss
she did something horrible and made a
deal with a demon to transfer her soul
into a nearby mirror but this cost her
her soul and when she dies the demon
will eat her soul for good okay Mirano
clearly did all of this cuz a demon
screwed her over I get it but in reality
she still could have used the demon to
save herself and still keep her soul let
me explain if we look at history there
are a few examples of people worming
their way out of deals made with the
devil like with the story of the man
named Stingy Jack Jack was at a bar but
didn't have any money he called the
devil to come have a drink with him but
then asked if the devil could change
himself into a coin under the condition
that the devil could claim Jack's Soul
when he dies Jack agreed and the devil
turned into a coin but Jack later then
stole the devil coin back and put him in
his pocket where he also kept a silver
cross this made the devil unable to
escape until Jack finally led him under
the condition that his soul would not be
taken when he died and this allowed Jack
to get the devil to pay for his drink
for free and well yes it is a silly
story it points out a key factor that if
Mirano managed to to outsmart the demon
through deception and the devil being
well the master of Lies he would have
respected getting a taste of his own
medicine and would have left her alone
even if Mirano could not have predicted
her getting betrayed if I was her I
would have made the same deal with the
demon without actually making a deal if
we look at various religious text that
tells us what demons really are they are
deceivers by nature and they lie they
also know that if they ever revealed
their true selves to us and what they
actually wanted then no one would ever
make a deal with them also in the good
old book since the big man took the sins
out of the world and defeated the devil
way back devils and demons legally know
that they're not actually allowed to
take or possess ever again this means
that any deal made with them is only
conducted through falsehood and
deception selling us a deal but they
aren't even capable of selling anything
in the first place because of this no
deal with anything demonic is actually
100% binding we likely would have been
able to outsmart the demon you know
medieval courtroom drama type Style by
proving our case using religious text to
basically proved to him that the only
thing he could claim was nothing because
his deal isn't worth anything mirano's
mother is shocked and questions how long
she can keep being evil because this is
causing everybody she loves to leave her
realizing how alone she is she gets mad
and creates a magical storm around her
telling these two that she has nothing
anymore except for her friend king boss
and they'll be together and happy one
day again and Boi realizes how much of a
loner she really is desper shows Boi a
preview of mirano's painful past
memories he tells them that while he
does feel bad for her nobody can save
her and he asks if Boi has what it takes
to kill her when the time comes back in
the real world the boys try to keep
fighting Oaken just as Arrow stab him
Damas realizes hakaru helped and wasn't
useless for once and is proud of him but
that's when he sees him get stabbed
because he really is useless Marano then
returns into her mirror and she now
feels like something within her has
changed with everyone defeated Oaken
approaches Morano and asks what his next
order is but she gets confused and
starts crying desper wakes up returned
from the brink of death snapping out of
confusion he thinks Morano is the one
who saved him he quickly tells kagi that
he needs to get the captain nearby to
heal him or they'll soon die but Oaken
senses the captain healing himself and
stabs him again spotting KAG nearby and
he gets ready to kill him and that's
when king boss finally shows up out from
hiding everybody is confused whose side
he is on he knocks out Boi KAG and
everyone else approaching desper he
thanks him for training Boi and making
him a worthy King he then shockingly
heals everybody using half of all his
energy confusing everybody more since he
just beat the out of them and BBA
then realizes that king boss must be
using D's powers that he inherited from
his mother Queen healing seeing Boi
fully healed KAG rushes over to his best
friend and him Boi and desper all get
happy for a minute and Boi tries to face
Oaken again but king boss stops him and
desper tells him that only king boss can
fight him not knowing his true
intentions desper thinks about taking
both of these Fighters out because boss
realizes that he used half of his energy
okay now while this fight may seem
impossible our daddy right now has shown
that he has officially gone insane he
tried to kill us then felt sorry and
says he likes us but also wants morcha
to be happy but she wants to kill us and
also really what it's very confusing
from the current circumstances it's
clear that pops is really well whipped
and also displayed parenting traits if
we think about it there's no rush to
solve our daddy problem DA's already
trapped he's not going anywhere Oak is
trapped Morano is chill and all of our
allies are healed up and back to normal
so why Rush at this point it would be
useless remember that boss's soul is
tied to Morano by pretending to let Boss
rule we could have easily plotted with
our teammates to destroy Morano at any
point later these guys really just they
rush through for no reason he quickly
cautions Boi that they don't know who's
really on their side and they should
stand back while they watch this epic
battle unfold Oaken rushes king boss but
his sword breaks on his skin watching
this desper suspects that King boss's
Soul inside of his son's di his body and
not his Giant's body his durability must
be concentrated into a smaller form and
then he watches the king destroy ogan's
face meanwhile aay tells Boi that if his
father loses the battle they're all dead
but if he wins it will be up to Boi to
take out his father as they watch Oaken
keeps regenerating while boss keeps
destroying him realizing he needs a new
plan boss destroy destroys Oaken one
more time collecting his body parts but
this time crushes him into a tiny ball
and takes out this huge Rock and inserts
all of oaken's body parts into this hole
trapping him from expanding sealing him
inside and winning the battle knowing
the time has finally arrived Boi gets
ready to fight his father bag tells him
to maybe forget what he said because
boss seems way more powerful than he
thought he walks over to Mirano and she
confesses that she went crazy trying to
do everything to help him reach his goal
and almost ruined his real family life
but Boston realizes that Morano gave up
her dreams to help him and she ended up
with nothing feeling bad he says he'll
end their suffering and go out together
if he loses this final battle he then
challenges Boi and his men to join aide
or die but Boi's men all side with him
and get ready to put their lives on the
line for him and Boi quickly stops them
and challenges his father head on Boss
attacks him with his massive strength
but boji uses his Nimble size and power
to avoid each hit using his special
strength to find the weak point of his
father's sword he breathes and slowly
breaks down its strength and then he
finally sees the weak point the final
one he charges in one more time upon
impact but Dodges boss's weapon hitting
its weak point and scaling it running up
his father's head and he takes him out
once and for all destroying his
signature weapon and winning the battle
shocking everybody boss then goes to
apologize to Morano and prepares to end
both of their suffering but Boi knocks
him out meanwhile in the underground
King desha gets a visit from this man he
asks King desha if he wants to move off
to number one from number two since king
boss is about to die and if he accepts
he'll be able to go to the king's
treasure room and if they go there he
might find something in there that might
help him save Oaken from immortality but
Desa says he doesn't need to because his
brother desper has a crazy plan to save
Oaken back on Earth Boi tells boss that
he wants da to come back and apologize
to Boi da amarano apologize to Boi for
being selfish and not letting her live
her dream boji then grants His Wish
destroys the mirror and sets boss
amarano Soul free and that's when the
demon shows up seeing their souls try to
go to heaven the demon jumps up to grab
them but the captain slows him down
forcing him to lose his speed marango
Soul then thinks fast and shoves boss's
soul out of the way saving him
sacrificing herself for him yet again
meanwhile the real daa is shown a
flashback of his father and Morano's
time together and sees how she gave up
her peaceful life to boss make a deal
with the devil in order to become the
strongest man in the world how that
demon stole Boi's true Powers before he
was born in order to make that happen
makes him sad for his little big brother
he then hears his father's voice telling
him to save Morano and he finally wakes
up in his original body for the first
time since this video Boi then signals
that his men need to stop the demon and
desper calls on his brother to strike
him with a lightning bolt just as the
captain cuts off his head desper quickly
runs to pick it up and says that he
would only give it back if the demon
grants them a wish but da then steals
des's Wish by yelling for him to bring
Morano back to life making her appear
right in front of him and making desper
really sad and then the demon leaves
feeling bad he then states that he will
make it up to them and desper then
realizes that his bro is Immortal so
they can always try to save him later #
no worries feeling better he asks da to
reward him with a crap ton of cash da
announces that he will marry Morano and
thanks everybody for their service he
offers his crown back to Boi shocking
him and and then Queen healing finally
shows up and discovers that her little
boy is getting married to this strange
girl which is wo and she also finds out
that it's Mirano which makes her really
mad for hot SEC but she forgives him and
ends up being really happy for her kids
because cool and then showing emotions
for the first time ever everybody's
happy it's great and they announce that
Boi is the new king and KAG then sneaks
off from the castle thinking that Boi
doesn't have any use for him anymore
especially since he is a well no good
thief elsewhere Boi quickly finds out
the KAG is missing sad without his best
friend his mother turns over a new leaf
and tells him that he doesn't have to be
king if he doesn't want and to go after
what truly makes him happy boji then
happily offers the kingdom back to his
brother and leaves to find KAG finding
him they romance and he tells KAG that
they will both go off into the sunset
and make their own kingdom together cuz
cool cuz they're going to do things just
like how their daddy did it make their
own kingdom meanwhile back in the
underground King Dasha finally gets word
that his brother's plan to save Oaken
have failed pissing him off with no
options left to help his brother Oaken
he agrees to become promoted as the
number one ranked king of the world and
he gets LED down into the magical
treasury but what do you guys think
about the video don't forget to like
subscribe and leave a thumbs up down
below and as always don't forget to
check out our how toe playlist